♪ ♪
>> Greg: LIVE PD HAS BEEN
POLLED.
THE SHOW WAS A HIT WITH THE
UNSPEAKABLE TRUTH THAT COPS ARE
HUMAN.
MAYBE THAT IS WHY IT WAS
CANCELED AND SHOWING THE PLACE
HAS HARDWORKING FOLKS FACING
UNPREDICTABLE AND SOMETIMES
DANGEROUS CIRCUMSTANCES.
BECAUSE THAT DIDN’T FIT THE
CURRENT NARRATIVE, IT GOT
PULLED.
THE REAL CENSORSHIP DOESN’T
ARRIVE WITH HYPOCRISY BUT THE
EMASCULATION OF NETWORK EXECS.
HERE IS AN IDEA, REPLACE LIVE PD
WITH NO PD TO SHOW CRIMES
COMMITTED WITHOUT COPS AROUND.
OH, YEAH, THAT WAS A RIOT.
BUT THE NETWORK MADE SURE NOT TO
SHOW MUCH OF THAT.
SO WILL LIVE PD COME BACK?
NOT WHEN THE MEDIA SEES POLICE
AS SOMEHOW WORSE THAN CRIMINALS.
LIVE PD’S CRIME IS SHOWING
REALITY OF POLICING IGNORED BY
OTHER NETWORKS WHERE COPS ARE
RELENTLESSLY HEROIC OR DEFIANTLY
BAD.
SO AME CANCELED IT, CENSORSHIP
OUT OF FEAR.
DO YOU KNOW THAT UP TO 440,000
AMERICANS DIE EACH YEAR FROM
PREVENTIVE HOSPITAL ERRORS?
THE THIRD LEADING CAUSE IN THE
U.S.
SO SHALL WE CANCEL
"GREY’S ANATOMY" AND ALL THOSE
OTHER HOSPITAL PROGRAMS THAT
SHOW HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN AN
ASPIRATIONAL GLOW?
AND BELIEVE ME, I ALL OF THIS
KNOWING FULL WELL LIVE PD WAS MY
COMPETITION.
THEY PUT UP GREAT NUMBERS EVERY
SATURDAY NIGHT AND I SHOULD BE
THRILLED THAT THEY GOT KNOCKED
OUT OF THE LINEUP.
I COULD BE NUMBER ONE.
BUT THAT IS STUPID AND WRONG
BECAUSE I MAY NOT BE NUMBER ONE.
I MAY BE NEXT.
SO JESSE, YOU WERE A BIG FAN OF
THE SHOW AND I WAS IFFY BECAUSE
I DIDN’T LIKE LIVE PROGRAMMING
SHOWING PEOPLE AT THEIR WORST
CIRCUMSTANCES, YOU KNOW, WHEN
YOU ARE DRUNK AND DO SOMETHING
STUPID.
>> Jesse: THAT IS LIKE TO
SHOW.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: YES, IT IS.
SO I ALWAYS FELT A BIG LESSON
FROM LIVE PD WAS HOW SUBSTANCES
PLAYED A ROLE IN LIKE 90% OF
THESE CONFLICTS.
SOMEBODY IS WASTED AND THAT
UNRAVELS.
IT IS A LESSON.
>> Jesse: IT SHOWS YOU THE
HUMAN CONDITION, ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU GOT TO SEE THE
METHAMPHETAMINES AND HEROIN THAT
RAVAGED LARGE PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
LIKE YOU SAID TO COMMIT HUMAN
EYES AS THE POLICE.
IT GAVE YOU A CRASH COURSE IN
CRIMINAL LAW.
IF YOU GET PULLED OVER FOR THE
SMALL AMOUNT OF CANNABIS, YOU
DON’T HAVE TO RESIST OR RUN
AWAY.
RELAX.
AND IF YOU ARE COOPERATIVE AND
POLITE AND RESPECTFUL, THE
POLICE USUALLY GIVE YOU A PASS.
"LIVE PD" WAS THE TRUTH.
IT WAS LIVE, UNSCRIPTED,
UNEDITED PROGRAMMING.
ISN’T THAT WHAT WE WANT?
DON’T WE WANT MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS TO BE WATCHING WHAT
THE COPS ARE DOING ON THE
WEEKEND?
DON’T WE WANT TRANSPARENCY, BODY
CAMERAS, FULL ACCOUNTABILITY?
THIS IS WHAT THIS WAS, A MILLION
IN THE DEMO AND ALMOST AS GOOD
AS YOU GREG, MILLION IN A DEMO.
WHICH IS ASTOUNDING AND SHOWS
YOU HOW MANY PEOPLE WATCH THE
SHOW.
A BLACK AMERICANS, WHITE
AMERICANS, HISPANIC-AMERICANS
BECAUSE EVERY HOUR ONE OF THE
BYSTANDERS OF THE SUBJECT WOULD
LOOK AT THE CAMERA AND SAY
"LIVE PD," WHAT UP?
IT WAS PROBABLY INTERNAL
PRESSURE THAT CAME.
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO BOYCOTTED
TIM SPEAR THERE WAS NO MASS
INSURRECTION ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
I THINK THEY PANICKED AT A&E AND
MADE COPS LOOK GOOD OR THEY WERE
GUILTY OR JUST SCARED, BUT THIS
HURTS SOCIAL JUSTICE.
THIS DOESN’T HELP SOCIAL
JUSTICE.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, JUAN I CALL
IT CENSORSHIP WHICH I REALIZE
THE STRICT DEFINITION IS NOT
BECAUSE THIS IS PRIVATE
COMPANIES.
THEY CAN CANCEL A SHOW WHENEVER
THEY WANT, BUT IT IS A FORM OF
CENSORSHIP WHEN PEOPLE DECIDE TO
CLOSE SOMETHING DOWN BECAUSE
THEY ARE SCARED OF COME I DON’T
KNOW, THE MEDIA?
IT IS AN EXTERNAL PRESSURE THAT
CAUSES YOU TO RUN AWAY.
IT IS A DIFFERENT, A NEW KIND OF
CENSORSHIP.
>> Juan: SO I HAVE A DIFFERENT
TAKE, GREG.
I WAS THINKING MAYBE IT IS
INTERNAL PRESSURE AND MAY BE AN
ACT OF CONSCIOUSNESS.
MAY BE ATTUNED TO THE FACT THAT
IN THE CULTURE RIGHT NOW IS SO
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT THE POLICE
HAVE WITH SO MANY IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY BUT IN THE COMMUNITY
IN GENERAL IN TERMS OF THE USE
OF EXCESSIVE FORCE.
SO THEY SAY IT’S JUST NOT RIGHT
NOW.
BY THE WAY, I PREDICTED TO JESSE
THAT A&E WOULDN’T CANCELED THE
SHOW BECAUSE THE SHOW WAS
POPULAR.
I THINK IT IS THE NUMBER 1 SHOW
ON A&E.
>> Greg: YES, IT IS.
>> Juan: THEY TOOK A REAL
STEP, A REAL SACRIFICE BY DOING
THIS.
BUT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IT
OFTENTIMES RESULTS IN A VERY
NEGATIVE PORTRAYAL NOT ONLY OF
BLACK PEOPLE BUT WITH TINO’S,
EVEN POOR WHITE PEOPLE.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY ARE NOT GOING
INTO BIG LAW FIRMS IN PLANNING A
DRUG DEALER IN THE BATHROOM.
THIS OF STREET CRIME SO A HEAVY
LOAD OF PEOPLE IN THE STREETS.
INTO MY MIND, YOU KNOW I CAN SAY
THIS DIRECTLY TO ALL OF YOU.
WOULD YOU WANT A TV CAMERA IN
YOUR FACE ON THE WORST DAY OF
YOUR LIFE?
WOULD YOU WANT THAT TO BE SEEN
BY ALL OF AMERICA, THE WORST DAY
OF YOUR LIFE?
I JUST THINK THAT SHOWS
BASICALLY WHAT IT BOILS DOWN TO,
KIND OF, YOU KNOW A PEEK LOOK AT
PEOPLE AND THEIR MOST
DISTRESSED, AWFUL CONDITION.
>> Greg: I ALWAYS FELT LIKE I
AGREE WITH THAT PART, BUT I
DON’T THINK THAT IS THE REASON
WHY IT IS BEING CANCELED.
EMILY COME I WANT TO PLAY YOU A
CLIP FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT
WE JUST HEARD MOMENTS AGO ABOUT
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF WE DIDN’T
HAVE POLICE.
>> I’M THINKING WHAT HAPPENS
LATE AT NIGHT WHEN YOU MAKE THAT
CALL TO 911 AND THERE WAS NOBODY
THERE?
WHAT DO YOU DO?
WHETHER WHITE, BLACK, OR ANYBODY
ELSE, WHAT DO YOU DO?
YOU ARE DARLING AND SOMEBODY
BREAKING INTO YOUR HOUSE.
THAT HAPPENS TO BE A VIOLENT
PERSON?
>> Greg: EMILY YOU HAVE A
CHOICE AND YOU CAN DISCUSS THAT
TOPIC OR THE TOPIC WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT ON "LIVE PD"?
IT IS UP TO YOU.
>> Emily: THANK -- THANK YOU.
WE NEED MORE FOOTAGE AND NOT
LESS.
I WANT PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
24 HOURS AFTER VOLUNTARY
SURRENDER OF MOTHER STATE AND
WOMEN’S JAILS ON CHRISTMAS AT
PRISONS, EVERYTHING.
WHAT IS PRINTED ON THE OUTSIDE,
GOING TO THE CAFETERIAS AND THE
PUBLIC NEEDS TO SEE THE SEE THE
ENTIRE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND NOT LESS.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, DANA THIS
IS A PROGRAM OWNED BY DAN ABRAMS
AND ALSO OWNED SOMETHING CALLED
MEDIA HIKE.
I’M SURE THAT WON’T GET
CANCELED, BUT HE’S A LIBERAL.
HE IS A THOUGHTFUL, LIBERAL
DEMOCRAT.
AND HE’S BEING EATEN ALIVE BY
HIS OWN.
>> Dana: SO, WHAT IS
INTERESTING IS I THINK IN SOME
OF THE PROPOSED LEGISLATION,
FEDERAL MONEY DID NOT GO TO THE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS THAT DO NOT
HAVE EVERYBODY IN BODY CAMS.
RIGHT?
SO THIS FOOTAGE IS IMPORTANT IN
SOME WAYS, RIGHT?
SO THEY WILL WANT THAT.
I HAVE A HARD TIME EVER WATCHING
ANY OF THESE SHOWS BECAUSE I
HATED THE FEELING IS THAT I GOT
FROM IT.
I WOULD GET SO NERVOUS FOR
EVERYBODY.
I REMEMBER GETTING PULLED OVER
ONE TIME FOR SPEEDING TICKETS,
AND I WAS MORTIFIED.
I WANTED TO PUNISH MYSELF.
I FEEL BAD FOR ABRAMS BECAUSE I
THINK HE HAD A GOOD PRODUCT AND
THEY MADE A DECISION, THIS WILL
DISAPPOINT A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> Greg: YOU WERE RIGHT TO BE
NERVOUS, DANA, PULLED OVER
SPEEDING.
YOU LEFT OUT THE FACT THAT YOU